So I'm an evolutionary biologist.
The thing I love most
about evolution is the story.
Evolution is a single story
that links every species,
every branch in the tree of life together.
It's this sense of connectivity
with the rest of the living world.
It's like one of the reasons why I became
a biologist in the first place.
Now, when Charles Darwin, my man Chuck D,
when he first proposed this theory ...
(Laughter)
When he first proposed
the theory of evolution,
he imagined it as this slow,
gradual process
that played out over thousands
or millions of years.
But now, in the face of all
the different changes
that we are making to the planet,
we're finding that evolution is rapidly
altering species around our planet
in order to live alongside us.
And in our short time on this planet,
we have trimmed, trained
and reshuffled the tree of life
at breakneck speed.
10,000 years ago,
we had already learned how to manipulate
the basic building blocks of life,
turning wild plants and animals
into domesticated forms
to use for our own purposes.
With mass global transportation,
we've reshuffled species around the globe,
bringing them together and forming
all new ecological interactions.
And on top of that,
we've fundamentally altered
Earth's surface and its climate
through industrialized
agriculture, urbanization,
pollution and global warming.
Now I've dedicated my life
to trying to understand
the lasting biological impacts
of our human footprint.
One of the things that I've learned
along the way is that life is a paradox.
It's simultaneously incredibly fragile
and relentlessly resilient.
The thing that impresses me most
is that despite our devastating
impacts on this planet,
I'm constantly in awe
of the surprising, incredible,
amazing ways that life is changing,
evolving and adapting
to a time that's literally defined
by our species' impact on the planet.
We now live in a time where one half
of the human species lives in cities.
As urban areas grow and expand,
life around the world,
non-human life, is changing
to figure out how to exploit
the novel resources
and avoid the potential dangers.
My research group and my colleagues
have been studying these small lizards
called anoles
that occur across the island
of Puerto Rico.
Now, most of the time,
these lizards spend their time
running up and down trees,
chasing after insects, doing the things
you know, that lizards do.
But in cities, they have evolved
at the genetic level.
They've evolved longer limbs
and larger sticky toe pads
to utilize the sides of buildings
and artificial surfaces like glass
and metal and concrete as their homes.
They've also evolved
greater heat tolerance
to deal with the high temperatures
that define dense urban environments,
what we call urban heat islands.
And what's more, is that multiple
populations of this species
have come up with the same solutions
over and over again, independently.
Showing us that not only is the process
of evolution very rapid sometimes,
but in some cases it can also
be quite predictable.
Now, urbanization is not
our only impact on this planet,
far from it.
Perhaps our earliest
and longest-lasting impact
has been through our want and need
to hunt other species
for food and for sport.
I spent the last few years studying
the evolution of African elephants
in response to ivory poaching.
In Mozambique,
there was a civil war from 1977 to 1992.
During this time,
in Gorongosa National Park,
elephants in particular
were reduced by 90 percent
because of the ivory trade,
being targeted for their trademark tusks.
Now, under most circumstances,
African elephants have tusks,
all males have tusks,
the vast majority of females have tusks.
But there is a small number
of females that carry a gene
that prevents them
from growing their tusks.
But after the Mozambican Civil War,
one-half of the surviving females,
completely tuskless.
Now, during a time
where individuals are being hunted
specifically for a trait,
having tusks,
not having that trait puts you
at a decided advantage
in your ability to survive.
That in and of itself
is natural selection.
Those surviving females then went on
and passed that gene on
to many of their daughters.
That turnover of genes across generations,
that is rapid evolution
in this long-lived species
in response to a decade and a half
of human hunting.
I remember going to Gorongosa
for the first time
and participating
in these elephant captures
where we collar these individuals
and collect data
and track their movements.
And we came across this female,
and she's old enough where we know
that she had survived
the Mozambican Civil War.
Now we sedated this female
and as we were there,
sort of working up all of these data,
looking into her big, groggy, sleepy eyes,
and it really struck me, the impact
that our species can have
on the rest of the living world.
This female, she lived during a time
that saw nine out of ten of the members
of her species slaughtered.
But she survived.
She grew up, she went on
and had children, had grandchildren,
became the matriarch of a family group.
But what strikes me
the most about this story
is that the reason
for all of that destruction
and that slaughter
was simply because
humans like to make trinkets
out of their teeth.
Which is about the most
ridiculous and sad thing
I've ever had to say out loud.
But we live in a time where
even the simplest human whims
can fundamentally alter
the evolutionary fate
of the largest land animal on our planet.
And many of these stories
of rapid evolution are sad,
but some also offer us hope
for our own future on this planet.
In nature's struggle to deal with all
the nonsense that we're throwing at her
in all these different ways,
some of those solutions
may lead us to novel insights
that may help our bodies
deal with things
that we currently struggle with
that will allow us to survive
all the different changes
that we're making on this planet.
For instance, fast forward
to the year 2040,
it's estimated that there will be
about 30.2 million new cancer cases
diagnosed in that year alone.
Now, we know a lot
about the genes and mutations
that are responsible for many cancers
or make an individual
more predisposed to getting cancer.
We know a lot less about potential
genetic mutations or variation
that may make an individual more resistant
or more resilient to cancer.
But perhaps nature
has already found the solution.
April 26th, 1986,
the day before my very first birthday.
There was an explosion
in the Chernobyl nuclear power plant.
Humans were immediately evacuated
from that region,
what is now called
the Chernobyl exclusion zone.
But in the decades since,
wildlife has actually moved
into the Chernobyl exclusion zone
and has proliferated.
So my research group and colleagues,
we have been studying the wolves
that live in the Chernobyl exclusion zone,
trying to understand how
they have responded biologically
to now generations of exposure
to elevated radiation levels.
Now, if we consider a wolf pup that's born
in the Chernobyl exclusion zone,
it lives every single day of its life,
from the time it's born,
gaining increased doses of exposure
from its environment.
With every meal that that animal eats,
it then gets another dose
of radiation from prey species.
And we can see that radiation
accumulating in this wolf population
in the form of cesium-137.
And one of the things
that our data are showing us
is that the fastest-changing regions
of the Chernobyl wolf genome
occur in and around genes
that we know are involved in cancer
or in the mammalian
anti-tumor immune response.
We're now working
with biomedical companies
and cancer biologists
to understand the physiological
impacts of these mutations
with the hope that at least
some of these changes
may lead us to novel therapeutics
that might result in new treatments
for cancer in humans.
In this grand story of life,
we're writing a brand new chapter.
Now our chapter in this story
is not a pretty one, let's be honest.
As a matter of fact,
there's a distinct possibility
that our species could bring about
Earth's sixth major mass extinction event.
So, you know, that sucks.
(Laughter)
It'd be messed up if I had just left
the talk like that, I was like,
"Hope you're all
proud of yourselves, bye."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
But luckily I don't have
to leave the talk like that
because this chapter
is still being written.
Our chapter in this story
of life is still happening,
which means that there are still
many possibilities ahead of us.
We have the possibility to act,
the possibility to fight for those species
that don't have the ability
to fight for themselves.
We have the possibility to turn
our chapter in this story
into one of redemption,
one of hope and one of care
for this epic legacy of life
on this planet that we've inherited.
A legacy, by the way,
that's four billion years in the making.
Which brings up the possibility
that we can pass on a world to our kids
and our grandkids
so that they can enjoy and revel
in the incredible biodiversity
that the story of evolution has produced.
What Charles Darwin referred to
as “endless forms most beautiful.”
One way or another, what we do matters.
We live in a time
when we are literally
etching our decisions
into the DNA of the species
that live in, on and around us.
When we're considering
this story that we're writing,
what do we want our chapter
in this grand story of life to be?
Thank you.
(Applause)